what do you what do you think because
like when your dad ran and I'm sure this
will be part of him running again the
whole point is still anti-establishment
we've been talking about it the whole
time like from separated whatever the
fact that now I feel like every time you
open your mouth there's somebody that
talks about you becoming the president
of the United States of America people
are chanting it when you're at one of
these rallies you were talking about
they're talking about it on the TV shows
you go to the idea that what was this
sort of outsider revolution regime thing
is is could be it dynasty and there are
people who are supporting the idea that
after 2020 going into 2024 should your
dad be successful or who knows maybe
should he not be successful you just
wait for years maybe they run in 2020
[Laughter]
you've seen the way this works out right
you've seen four years of it or so is
that something that you could see in
your future down the road looking past
2020 listen you know I've enjoyed the
game I seems like you do I do Alice I I
like like you know when they start hey
I'm not gonna lie right it's sort of
cool if you're in a stadium of 15,000
people and they start chanting 46 when
you're speaking it's like now listen my
only focus is getting my father
reelected because I believe he's doing
the right things for America I get I
like the fight I think you know for for
better or worse I got that sort of Trump
gene that could handle sort of that
pressure aspect that doesn't bother me
if people are pushing back and writing
bad like I just I'm not that fazed by it
you know I don't know that I'd like the
day job and that's a big part of it
right you know campaign you know I gotta
make sure I would want that in time so
you know it's it's an honor I mean it's
you know I can't I can't say that
doesn't feel good but you know I don't I
have no plans for it right now you know
people are always like oh he's running I
got no no I just can't say no because in
this day and age if I say yeah oh I'm
not gonna do that
Oh twelve years later no you're a liar
twelve years ago you went on Jim Norton
and Sam Robert you said you were gonna
do this therefore you know I just I
don't want to be that guy but like
listen I see the results man I you know
and again whether it's sort of my
hobbies are you hunting fishing shooting
all the stuff egg I've I have seen
middle America and it wasn't like I just
magically appeared there you know once
we got into politics like I have friends
all over the place there because that's
sort of where I spend my free time I'm
actually probably much more comfortable
there than I am in New York City I can't
see me on like the you know the New York
City sort of like BS like rubber chicken
you know charity dinner [ __ ] circuit
like you know where everyone just goes
kisses their own asses it's like it's
not me it never has been so you know I
think I get it and so when I go around
those places and I see the results and I
see these people I said it last night
like you see like a grown man like
coming like hey like I was able to start
this business because of these policies
because it would see a grown man in
tears talking about this or they man in
New Hampshire was sort of interesting is
there just by chance like in between
stops where I was going to like thank
people who are working on our teams to
be like okay let's go to this coffee
shop but just got it you know get some
caffeine and I don't want to be called
low-energy jib we went into one got
another one still a trump you know go
into this coffee shop and you know 23
year old female you know it just got out
of like culinary school and like she
literally started her own business she's
got this great coffee shop and I'm like
hey this okay you know coffee shop you
know female young like this is not I
love what you guys are doing thank you
so much for all like making this
possible for me in this town which I
never thought like man it's awesome
right was rewarding feels it really
feels good and so you know like I said
my father didn't need this job but you
know the fact that he's getting the
results that he's had you know what and
again you know it's not like what the
media tries to portray